Moin Leute, heute wird Ikea-Krampel Custom-Firmware flashed und habt ihr es gesehen, Julian BAM
wurde gehackt.
Ich verfolge den Channel nicht, aber ich finde es immer bedenklich, wenn so große Channels
mit angeblich Triple-Factor-Authentifizierung übernommen werden.
Ich weiß nicht was war, ehrlich gesagt, wie, ich tippe mal drauf, wer hat sich irgendein
Virus, Trojaner, was auch immer eingefangen, der dann im Prinzip das alles über seinen
Rechner gemacht hat, wo er angemeldet war, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, keine Ahnung,
weiß es nicht.
Und das ist aber immer ein bisschen bedenklich, weil es besteht ja immer noch die Möglichkeit,
dass es Schwächen in der 2-3-Factor-Authentifizierung gibt von irgendwelchen Anbietern.
Ich meine, da gucken 30.000 Leute drauf, die schlau sind, schlauer als wir alle zusammen,
die sich um so Sachen wie Google-Anmeldungen und sonst was kümmern, na gut, 30.000 vielleicht
ein bisschen übertrieben, übertrieben, lass es mal 50 sein oder so, aber das ist schon
gut durchdacht.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er sich auf seinem Rechner was eingefangen hat, wahrscheinlich
ist aber keine Ahnung, was da war.
Sabun für den IQ-Boost, das ist eine gute Entscheidung, du bist eh in der Abo-Falle,
Sabun ist vorbei.
SMS, 2-Factor-Authentifizierung, ja gut, das kommt ja manchmal vor, dass findige Leute,
die deine Nummer wissen, beim Anbieter anrufen und sagen, was weiß ich, ist Handy verloren,
neue Adresse und so was und der Anbieter ist dann so blöd und schickt dir eine SIM-Karte
und so was, ja, deswegen verrate ich auch keine meine Handy-Nummer und außerdem ist
es am besten, man macht 2-Factor-Authentifizierung dann, wie anders, SMS finde ich ein bisschen
oldschool, da ist tatsächlich irgendeine Authenticator-App irgendwie besser.
Du kannst das so abfangen, ist ja noch schlimmer, ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ich muss erstmal kurz hydrate stain, Leute, bevor ich anfange.
Passt das mal zusammen, also ich hab einen, pass mal auf, ich hab einen Ikea Windrick
Ning gekauft, ich hoffe, ich sprich das richtig aus, weil schwedisch ist nicht unbedingt
jetzt gerade, ich bin nicht unbedingt schwedisch native speaker, Windrick Ning und dort bauen
wir heute einen ESP32 ein oder einen ESP8266, ich weiß es noch nicht genau, mal gucken
ob der ESP32 da reinpasst, der D1-Mini ist ein bisschen größer und dann schließen wir
den da an und lesen mit dem ESP32 die Werte aus, weil der normale Sensor, der hat nur
so eine LED-Anzeige und zusätzlich, das können wir vielleicht auch noch mit in das
heute reinschreiben und zusätzlich schließen wir noch einen Bosch BME660, 680, weiß es
gerade aus dem Kopf nicht, einen Sensor an, der Gas, Luftdruck, Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit
mit ausliest, das heißt dann haben wir einen rundum Luftqualitätssensor, der mehr kann
als das Standard Ikea-Ding und per WLAN in die Heimautomatisierung eingebunden werden
kann, so das machen wir heute, was ist denn ein guter Fenstersensor, den man einfach
auslesen kann, ich vergesse manchmal ein Fenster zuzumachen, da würde ich dir tatsächlich
keine WLAN-Geräte empfehlen, weil WLAN-Geräte brauchen viel zu viel Strom, in der Regel,
Ausnahme besteht in die Regel, aber die Aqara-Dinger, wie auch immer man sie ausspricht, sind ganz
gut, also die da Dinger, wenn man jetzt frisch einsteigt, ist das kein schlechtes System,
die da zum Beispiel, nicht Temperatur, Door-Window-Sensor, die sind auch günstig, weiß gar nicht was
der Campbell gerade bei Amazon kostet, bei AliExpress kriegst du es oftmals sehr günstig,
für unter 10 Euro das Stück, musst du mal gucken, die gibt es in unterschiedlichen Ausführungen,
musst du mal ein bisschen schauen, aber die sind nicht schlecht, damit die funktionieren,
wir können mal bei AliExpress kurz gucken, bei AliExpress mache ich, AliExpress mache
ich nicht auf meinem Desktop auf, hallo Leute übrigens, moin, oh nein jetzt habe ich AliExpress
auch noch Benachrichtigungen zugelassen, ne ist dir das Hörschen für Ficken, nicht
dass ich nach Damenhörschen für Ficken gesucht hätte, aber ok, zu geil, die China-Chinesen
man, die haben keine Ahnung, was sie da eintragen, Hörschen für Ficken, so, guck mal, hier,
nächste, 21 Euro, 4 Stück, guck mal, das ist schön günstig, du musst aber gucken, dass
es die ZigBee-Variante ist, da muss man schauen, aber, ist das ZigBee, ist das ZigBee, ja,
die sind gut, du brauchst aber noch irgendeinen ZigBee-Stick, aber ZigBee-Stick kannst du
eh gebrauchen für so ziemlich alles an Sensoren, das ist eine gute Kombination, weil die Dinge
halten auch lang, da hast du 2-3 Jahre Batterielaufzeit, also Ikea-Dings ist da, du brauchst aber noch
einen Stick, entweder nimmst du einen ganz billigen ZigBee-Stick, oh wie heißen diese
ganz billigen C, sind die das, die die Leute auf YouTube verwenden, den würde ich dir
aber nicht empfehlen, das ist wirklich nur wenn es billig as fuck sein muss, ein guter
ZigBee-Stick ist zum Beispiel KonBee, KonBee 2-Stick, da braucht man keinen Account, das
ist alles offline, ja, hol dir so ein und damit kannst du nahezu alle ZigBee-Geräte,
die es gibt betreiben und dann holst du dir ein paar, holst du dir Acara-Sensoren oder
Aquara-Sensoren, ich weiß bis heute nicht, wie man den Krempel richtig ausspricht, am
besten, am besten halt über AliExpress, da kriegst du wie gesagt für unter 10€, 21,21
durch 4 sind 5,25€, also günstiger kriegst du den Kram nicht, wichtig ist halt, dass
es die ZigBee-Variante ist, achso für AliExpress, ja für AliExpress brauchst du einen Account
zum Bestellen, du kannst den Kram auch bei Amazon kaufen, da gibt es auch manchmal günstige
Angebote, aber hier guck mal, hier bezahlst du 15€ aktuell für einen Sensor und du bezahlst
bei AliExpress China-Chinese bezahlst du 5€, also du kriegst quasi 3 Sensoren für den
Preis von einem, also allein schon aus dem, aus dem Gesichtspunkt, ähm, nicht das nicht,
ja und die sehen hier relativ groß ein, die sind furzklein, die Dinger, die sind so lang
wie mein Daumen und so, die sind so groß, so lang und so dick wie mein Daumen, da ist
nicht viel dran.
Kannst auch den Sonoffstick kaufen, ich empfehle den Konbi-Stick, weil den hab ich auch und
der funktioniert wunderbar.
Genau, guck mal, wieviel gibt es denn hier, wieviel sind das, wieviel Stück, erkennt
sich jemand, soll ich das jetzt zählen oder was, 3 Pieces, jebaited man, hier sind irgendwie
8 Dinger drauf und da unten steht 3 Pieces, 4 Pieces, 2 Pieces, 3 Pieces, jebaited, musste,
musste mal gucken, kaufst du die billigsten, billigsten und dann hast du für 100€ dein
gesamtes Haus mit ausgestattet und hast gleichzeitig noch einen guten Zigbee-Stick, den du für
alle anderen Sachen verwenden kannst, so will ichs machen.
Auf Wish gibt es die billige, auf Wish gibt es alles billiger, plus dass es nicht ankommt
oder nicht, dass es was drauf steht, bei AliExpress hast du den großen Vorteil, du hast AliExpress
auch auf deiner Seite, weil das ist ja nur, das AliExpress ist ja eigentlich nur ein großer
Marketplace.
Und die sind da relativ coolant, wenn du sagst, mir wurde Mist geliefert, nichts geliefert,
sonst was, dann schicken die dir einfach die Kohle wieder und gut ist.
Wie leise ist die Musik, ja?
Ja, besser.
Mein Angebot war 22 für, echt, warte mal.
Ach, siehst du, ich hab mich jebaiten lassen, 4, 4 und das sind nur 2, keck wait, Alter.
You got jebaited, das ist immer noch billiger als bei Amazon, aber du kannst, gerade bei
dem Akara Zeug, kannst du manchmal auch bei Banggood gucken, was nichts hier irgendwie
mit zu tun hat oder so, Akara Door Sensor, die haben manchmal auch günstig, nur aktuell
nicht so, ich hab gelesen, dass es Probleme gibt mit den Schiffen hin und zurück aus
China und dass deswegen jetzt teurer ist, musst du gucken, aber das ist immer noch billiger
als mit Z-Wave anzufangen und es ist billiger als das meiste andere Zeug, kann man sich
eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Der Label-Champ, der ist noch nicht fertig, der Label-Champ, da gehts demnächst weiter,
heute machen wir erstmal Windrickning, Windrickning Modding.
Das können wir irgendwann mal angucken, wenn es uns langweilig ist, mach das mal auf.
Von 2014, ok, das war schon ein bisschen älter, klingt wie ein merkwürdiges Windows Tool,
ja das ist aber schwedisch, Windrickning heißt das, Windrichtung auf Deutsch, hier Ikea Windrickning
heißt Windrichtung.
Wofür Kastenfirmen unterstützt das Ding SIG B2M QTT, nö, das Ding hat keinerlei Funkverbindung,
das einzige, ich schließe das mal kurz an, dass ihr das seht, so, ich schließe das mal
kurz an.
Da kommen jetzt mal wieder meine 50 China-Chinesen-USB-Kabel zum Einsatz, ich hab mir irgendwann
mal ein 50er Park China-Chinesen-USB-Kabel gekauft und das war eine sehr gute Idee, weil
jetzt hab ich immer genug USB-Kabel und ich war damals schon glücklicherweise vorausschauend
genug mir die mit Mikro-USB und USB-C zu kaufen.
So, ich schließe das mal an, das einzige was dieser Sensor kann ist, ganz schön wackelig,
ich hoffe ich hab's hier irgendwie halb kaputt gemacht, also das einzige was dieser, so, das
einzige was dieser Sensor kann ist leuchten, wenn er an ist, ich mach mal kurz, dass ihr
das besser seht, mach ich mal kurz hier die Lampe aus, so, das einzige was der kann ist
leuchten, der hat keinen WLAN, der hat keinen Zigbee, der hat keinen Z-Wave, der hat keinen
Low-Energy-Bluetooth, der hat keine SIM-Karte, der hat nix, der hat keinerlei Funk-Anbindung
an dieser Sensor, aber das coole ist, dass Ikea nett war, Ikea hat die Pins innen drinne
alle dargelassen und hat nix versucht irgendwie zu verschlimmbessern, das heißt wir haben
alle Pins und kommen easy dran, zumindest hab ich das gesehen in einem Video, das werden
wir jetzt ausprobieren, ob das alles so funktioniert.
Heute kein Battlefield 2042 Update, Leute, ich hab das, ich hab das Update gesehen zu
Battlefield 2042, ich muss echt, ich muss richtig cack, cack, dribble you und guckt
euch das mal an, ähm, patch notes, mega Update, da ist überhaupt nix, notes, ok, Battlefield
com, wir gucken mal auf Twitter, da ist das verlinkt, so, wisst ihr was das Schlimme
ist, ihr wisst ja was das Schlimme hier ist, dass sie das Update 4.0 nennen, das erweckt
den anschein, als ist dieses Spiel schon mal irgendwann bei 1.0 gewesen, wann soll denn
1.0 bitteschön stattgefunden haben bei Battlefield 2042, wenn das 4.0 ist, das ist, das ist
0.73 wahrscheinlich, ja, unten drunter steht lustigerweise 0.4, sie sind sich da selbst
nicht so ganz einig, wie das Ding jetzt heißt, also intern heißt es wahrscheinlich 0.4 und
die Marketing Abteilung hat 4.0 draus gemacht, aber es ändert sich ja auch nix, es ist ein
bisschen balancing tweaks und jetzt ist VoIP drin, ja super, es ist VoIP jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt
drin, wo keine Sau mehr drauf spielen spielt, top, perfekt, so muss, oh, das ist Hovercraft,
so muss das sein, Steam, schauen wir mal, ob das was bringt, oh ja, es gucken sich tatsächlich
400 Leute mehr das Spiel aktuell an, Massive, Alter, das wird's wahrscheinlich, guck mal,
das wird's wahrscheinlich mega rausreißen hier, Alter, uiuiui, neue Höhenfliege aber,
ist das gerade eine VM, nö, das ist Windows, das ist ganz normal Windows hier, Woman of
History, take the quiz, meine Taskleiste ist heute aber äußerst divers muss man sagen,
so, das hier ist eine VM, das hier ist eine VM, guck, das, die Ledungskiste ist eine VM
und das Windows Ding ist unten drunter, native, natürlich fühlen sich alle verarscht, der
einzige Grund, warum die dieses Spiel überhaupt noch weiter supporten und so große Reden schwingen
ist, dass die Leute, also dass sie das eben das Mindeste liefern, dass sie nicht bei den
Amis von irgendwelchen Sammelklagen betroffen werden oder so, die liefern 4 Spezialisten
und 4 Maps, weil sie das versprochen haben, sonst nichts, also nichts nennenswertes zumindest,
vielleicht mit den ein oder anderen geilen Skin oder so, das ist so eine Shitshow, das
ist so, was zu virtualisieren vor allem bei Workstation, oh ne, da heute fangen wir nicht
wieder mit dem Thema an, weil es sagt, weil sich ganz kurz gesagt, weil sich Linux unter
Windows besser virtualisieren lässt als Windows unter Linux, ohne durch zig Reifen springen
zu müssen, womit ich das umschalte mit Windows Boardmitteln, guck mal, du kannst doch bei
Windows mittlerweile, kannst du noch verschiedene Desktops anlegen, das macht übrigens dieses
Symbol hier unten, wenn ich weiß, was das macht, dafür ist das da und dann kannst du
Control Windows rechte Pfeiltaste drücken und linke Pfeiltaste und die Desktops durch
switchen und ich hab auf dem zweiten Desktop einfach Linux und ich schalte dann zwischen
dem ersten Desktop und dem zweiten Desktop um, das ist eigentlich ziemlich, Windows Taste
und Tab, ne das funktioniert nicht, Windows Taste und Tab ist Taste, du kannst es dann
hier mit der Maus machen ja aber, aber das ist nicht so schön ne, also besser ist Control
Windows rechts links, ja weirdchamp ne, wirechamp, ja beste Entscheidung ist nicht zu kaufen,
hast du noch Android auf dem, ja ja ja, ich hab das jetzt eigentlich komplett fertig eingerichtet
aber ich muss jetzt meinen alten Server noch ausstecken und hab mich nicht dazu durchringen
können bisher, vor allem bei Workstation, welche Version, ich glaub 16 ist das noch,
was sind die aktuelle, ist egal, ist egal, hier Control, ich benutze das seit 5 Jahren
oder so, so, das heißt die letzten zig vor immer Version funktionieren einfach, ist
egal ob du die neu start oder eine ein bisschen älter ist, Windows Taste plus V, das ist
die Clipboard Historie, ja klar, das ist tatsächlich eines der sinnvollsten Funktionen die sie
jetzt eingeführt haben, dass sowas dabei ist, endlich mal einer der hier die Emote
Vielfalt benutzt, was doch, natürlich funktioniert das, 100 Pro funktioniert das mit deinem Ryzen,
garantiert funktioniert, doch das war klar, warum soll vor allem bei Workstation mit deinem
Ryzen nicht funktionieren, warum soll das nicht gehen, klar funktioniert das, echt,
halt die 16er Version mit, ja dann nehmen wir halt irgendeine andere Version, warum hat
die 16er Version mit Ryzen Probleme, Kekwade, ich benutze Ruffy Clip oder wie das heißt,
ja ihr könnt in Google suchen was ihr wollt, plus nicht in Chat schreiben hier, ja wenn
du in Bios die Virtualisierungsfunktion eingeschaltet hast, ja keine Ahnung, Schelze von Nikso
S habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, also es wäre sehr merkwürdig, weil gerade im Server
Bereich auf Epic Basis ist ja Virtualisierungs eines der Dinger schlechthin, na gut, so also
wir kommen uns jetzt mal das Teil hier an, also ihr seht ja, aktuell ist es der Meinung,
wir haben hier super, super nice grüne Luft und so, übrigens ich muss euch was zeigen
Leute, ich weiß bloß nicht wie ich das machen soll, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wartet
mal, ich muss mal kurz hier, warte mal, ich muss mal schnell den, ja ja, den muss man
mal kurz raus machen, na auf, das ist jetzt China-Chinesen Zeug, das ist jetzt wieder
Müll, so, ich muss euch mal kurz was zeigen, aber dazu muss ich erstmal das Kabel hier
weg machen, da muss ich das Ding nochmal schnell richtig einstellen, dass das hier, so, ich
muss euch mal kurz was zeigen, keine Ahnung ob das funktioniert, Achtung, Achtung, ansonsten
muss ich mein T-Shirt ausziehen, das will ich jetzt aber nicht, aber ihr seht das eh
nicht, pass mal auf hier, guck mal, guck mal, Moment, Moment, Moment, seht ihr das?
Ne, Moment, Moment, ihr seht das nicht, ne, fuck, ähm, ich will jetzt mein Hemd nicht
ausziehen, aber ich ziehe jetzt mein Hemd aus, ich muss euch das zeigen, bestes T-Shirt,
MonkaS, MonkaS, ich weiß nicht genau warum, warum ich mir, ich mein ich bin, ich bin 37,
warum kaufe ich mir ein MonkaS-Shirt, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich finde es nice, gehst
du aus dem Haus mit dem, ja, aber meistens habe ich auch ein Hemd drüber, das siehst
du nicht, wirklich keine habe ich gerade so vor der Kamera gestanden, also nicht vor der
Kamera gestanden, so hier vom Tisch gestanden, keiner hat es gesehen, so ich muss jetzt mal
schnell was trinken und dann geht es los, also, was haben wir hier am Start, wir haben
einmal eine Ikea Windrickning am Start, pass mal auf, wir müssen erstmal kurz gucken ob
ich das richtig ausspreche, Alter, geh fort Microsoft man, Windrick, Ikea Wind, Achtung,
Windricknings, Windricknings, Windricknings, so falsch war ich gar nicht, schon nicht schlecht
gewesen, ja, also, einmal hier den Sensor, den machen wir dann gleich auf und gucken
da mal rein, also ich habe mir das im Vorfeld schon eingeschaut, wahrscheinlich ist das
so, hier unten ist ein Lüfter drin, hier ist der Luftqualitätssensor drin, hier oben
ist ziemlich viel Platz, ne, hier oben ist der Luftqualitätssensor drin, hier oben ist
relativ viel Platz, dass ich die Luft gescheit durch analysieren kann und hier unten müsste
noch Platz sein für den Controller, aufkriegen wir das hoffe ich mal irgendwie gleich damit
irgendwie mal schauen, so, dann habe ich noch ein ESP32, ne, ne das ist kein ESP32, ESP866,
aber ich würde es lieber mit dem ESP32 machen, da habe ich noch mehr von, vielleicht machen
wir das mit dem ESP32, wir testen mal, ich habe hier einen, wir testen mal ob das besser
reinpasst, schauen wir mal, also ich würde lieber den nehmen, die sehen jetzt auf den
ersten Blick, ich mache das mal kurz auf, die Controller sehen jetzt auf den ersten
Blick relativ gleich aus, aber das Ding hier, die Header brauchen wir nicht, ich gebe die
Header-Lahn, hier, die Dinger sehen auf den relativ gleich aus, aber, außer dass sie ein
bisschen unterschiedlich groß sind, aber der da ist billiger, der da ist billiger, dafür
ist der da deutlich leistungsfähiger, was ziemlich egal ist für diesen Anwendungszweck,
aber man darf nicht vergessen, wie weit wir mittlerweile 2022 sind mit Technik, ich meine
stellt euch mal vor, in so einem Teil hier, also der eigentliche Chip ist ja hier drunter,
das ist die Abdeckung, das hier ist die WLAN, das ist die Antenne hier unten, das schwarze,
da muss ich mal vorstellen, in so einem kleinen Chip ist ein 240MHz Dual Core, eigentlich
sogar ein Triple Core, es ist ein 240MHz Dual Core drinnen und ein 8MHz Low Power Prozessor,
also eigentlich hat das Ding 3 CPUs drauf, zig GPIO Pins, 4MB Flash, ich glaube 150K
RAM oder sonst was, aber allein schon 240MHz Dual Core, ich muss euch mal vorstellen, so
ein kleines Scheißding für 4,50€, kann man sich nicht beschweren, natürlich kann man
das nicht mit einem Pentium 2 vergleichen, und das ungekühlt und billig, es gibt garantiert
schon Doom auf dem ESP, das ist kein Ding, der hier, der ESP866 ist ein bisschen verbreitet,
also sie sind beide saumäßig verbreitet, das sind so die Go To China Chinesen Controller
und Chips eigentlich der letzten 5-6 Jahre, davor haben die Leute gerne Arduino verwendet,
aber so die letzten 5-6 Jahre sind eigentlich überall durch die Bank weg, an vielen Stellen
sowohl im Bastel Hobbybereich als auch viele professionelle Produkte die rauskommen, gerade
aus China, haben diese 2 Sachen drinnen, im Prinzip hauptsächlich früher den ESP866,
mittlerweile eher auch den ESP32, manche haben schon die ganz neuen ESP32C123 mit drinnen,
aber das ist wirklich nice, da fällt einem immer wieder auf, wie weit wir mit der Technik
mittlerweile schon sind, dass in so einem kleinen Furzding ein 240MHz Dual Core ist,
der kann sogar Raytracing, der kann theoretisch alles berechnen, was es gibt, weil da läuft
vollständig C, C++ drauf, aber er erhält nicht sonderlich schnell manche Sachen, ja
Der hier ist ein Ticken älter und ein großer Vorteil von beiden, von beiden ist, dass die
erstens Arduino kompatibel sind, das heißt man kann alle möglichen Arduino Libraries
zum größten, das heißt aber 99% der Arduino Libraries kannst du verwenden und das herstellereigene
Entwicklungskit ist auch relativ gut, obwohl es China Chinesen Zeug ist, du hast mittlerweile
eine Plattform I.O. Integration und kannst jeder Noob, der ein bisschen Ahnung davon
hat, aber wirklich, du musst damit noch nichts großartig gemacht haben mit Microcontroller
Kram, jeder Noob kann sich Visual Studio Code installieren, Plattform I.O. installieren
und über den Assistent sein erstes Programm dafür anlegen, geflasht und das ist auch
ein Vorteil gegenüber älteren Boards oder anderen Chips, du kriegst diese Boards immer
im handelsüblichen Micro-USB, das heißt du kannst den Krempel an PC anschließen und
direkt über den PC flaschen, das heißt du brauchst keinen Serial-USB Adapter oder
irgendwie so ein Blödsinn, das brauchst du zwar normalerweise für den ESP schon, aber
es gibt eigentlich keine Entwicklungs- oder keine so normalen Boards, die kein USB haben.
Die Dinger sind sogar relativ stromsparend, also man muss das ein bisschen relativieren,
also die Dinger sind an sich immer stromsparend, wenn man das mal mit einem Raspberry Pi oder
so vergleicht, also wenn die Dinger 150, 200 Mikroampere brauchen bei 5 Volt, dann ist
das schon viel, das brauchen die wenn das WLAN voll pullert, ansonsten brauchen die
irgendwie 80, 90, könnt ihr ja ausrechnen, 5 Volt mal 0,2, dann habt ihr das ganze in
Watt, also das braucht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, halbes Watt oder irgendwie sowas, die Dinger
brauchen nicht wirklich viel, also deutlich sparsamer auch als Raspberry Pi, vor allem
Sparsamer als Raspberry Pi 4, Vergleich mit dem Desktop PC müssen wir das gar nicht machen,
aber, was man nicht denken darf, ist, dass man damit jetzt irgendwelche batteriebetriebenen
Sachen machen kann, weil, wenn man so eine Batterie drinne hat, so ein ganz normal Lithium-Ionen-Akku,
was haben die 3,7 Volt oder so, oder 4,2 Volt vollgeladen haben die glaube ich, das passt
schon von der Stromversorgung her, aber die verbrauchen trotzdem zu viel, da hält da eine
die auch bloß eine Woche oder so, also für so ultra low power Batteriebetrieb sind die
Boards nicht gut, es gibt aber Boards, weil der ESP32 oder der ESP266 an sich, die verbrauchen
ziemlich wenig, aber die Zusatz-Hardware auf den Boards, ja manche schalten den USB, den
Spannungswander nicht ab, das geht immer über den Spannungswander drüber, manche versorgen
diesen USB, auf Serial geht es permanent mit Strom, es gibt Boards, die kommen auf, im Deep
Sleep, wo man gemerkt hat, man macht dann Sleep, lässt sich nicht permanent rödeln,
die kommen auf ungefähr, glaube ich, 10 micro Ampere im Deep Sleep und das ist dann schon
nice, da kannst du, wenn du 3-4 mal am Tag aufwachst, um neue Daten zu schicken, den Sensor
auch 2-3 Jahre laufen lassen irgendwo am Arsch der Welt, das funktioniert dann, da braucht
man aber spezielle Boards, die sind ein bisschen teurer, aber nicht viel, so, jetzt mal nur
so ganz kurz Exkurs über ESP32 und ESP266 und diese 2 Boards, die ihr hier seht, das
sind beides mit die beliebtesten, das ist ein ESP266 D1 Mini und das ist ein ESP32 D1 Mini,
es ist kein Original D1 Mini, es ist ein Nachbau, aber das ist China-Chinesen Zeug, der im
Prinzip eh immer und die funktionieren, NodeMCUs sind die anderen relativ verbreiteten Entwicklungsboards,
ja, gut, passt, so viel ESP32 Gelaber, machen wir mal die Header weg, die brauchen wir heute
eh nicht, so und jetzt gucken wir uns mal, achso, ja und eins habe ich auch noch, habe
ich ganz vergessen zu zeigen, ich habe noch ein, das liegt bei mir bestimmt schon seit
3 Jahren rum, lange auf jeden Fall, habe ich noch nie verwendet, das ist ein, wobei 3 Jahre
ist ein bisschen übertrieben, ein Jahr oder so liegt das hier rum, das ist ein BME 680
oder 680, das ist ein Sensor, der sieht zwar so klein und unscheinbar aus, was ist denn
das da eigentlich für einen Anschluss nehmen, hat jemand einen Plan, was das da für einen
Anschluss ist hier neben, guckt mal, was ist denn das, das schauen wir gleich mal, es steht
ja auch oben, was er macht, guckt mal, Luftdruck, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Temperatur und Gas, ne,
ne, das ist kein Mikro-USB, wir gucken, wir gucken gerade mal, was das, was das, was das
baut, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, das ist irgendwie ein Other Fruit, die sind normalerweise
viel zu teuer, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich mir das Ding mal irgendwann gekauft habe,
BME 680, ja, übrigens der Sensor ist fast mit das teuerste an dem ganzen Projekt, was
sind das hier neben für Anschlüsse, Finn, Dankeschön, das Motor kommt drauf, kein
ESP Home, was sind, was sind das für Connector, was, Stämmer Cute, ne, ne, wir löten das
schon dran, ach so, ok, das braucht nur wirklich niemand, also, ich meine, irgendwann muss
ich mein Lötkolm ja mal lohnen, den ich gekauft habe, ja, ich würde mir heute wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mehr das Ding für den Preis kaufen, aber egal, besser als weiter in der Tüte
liegen lassen und jetzt würde ich sagen, machen wir das Teil mal auf und gucken, wie das von
innen so aussieht, also Ziel ist folgendes, hier oben wahrscheinlich den Sensor rein,
hier unten eins der beiden Boards, ich vermute mal, der könnte bissi groß sein, der ESP32,
müssen wir mal gucken, schauen wir mal gleich, also so rum passt der gerade so, aber ich weiß,
mal schauen, wie viel Platz da hinten ist und hier unten das Board rein, so, fertig,
das ganze verbinden wir dann hier mit ein paar Kabels, schauen wir mal und wir löten
das ganze zusammen und lassen das auf, gucken erstmal, ob es funktioniert und dann machen
wir es zu. Willst du das Innenleben komplett austauschen? Nein, das ist doch gerade der
Sinn davon, das ist ein relativ günstiger Partikelsensor mit, ich glaube, 2,5 Nanometer,
ist es Nanometer, Mikrometer, Durchmesser, Partikelgröße, das ist relativ günstig für
den Sensor, der da drin ist, ich will das nicht aus, es bleibt alles so wie es ist, es kommt
nur zusätzlich, liegt im Namensschild, fuck, wo, wo es liegt? Oh ja, ich sehe es, Monka
League, alter, Wupp League, nee, nee, der hat die Partikelsache nicht, der hier ist nur
für Luftfeuchtigkeit, Luftdruck, Gas und Luftfeuchtigkeit, Temperatur und der Sensor
hier drin ist, der bleibt als Partikelsensor, so, also ihr seht, das sind halt ganz normale
Schraubsorn, muss ich mal gucken, ob wir das so auf, der da vielleicht, ja, gucken wir
mal, ich leg das mal ein bisschen so hin, weil, so, gucken wir mal rein, ich bin mal
gespannt, Windregning, da, erste Schraub, ich mag das immer nicht, wenn man nicht sieht,
wo man schraubt, kannst du ein Smart Mirror bauen, ja, ich habe gesehen, dass da Kappa
dahinter steht, aber, ich antworte jetzt trotzdem mal, ernst drauf, weil, Smart Mirror, ihr
wisst, dass ich Smart Home technisch, ja, also ich bastel so ziemlich alles, was es
gibt, was ich für sinnvoll halte, ich halte Smart Mirrors nicht für sinnvoll, deswegen
habe ich weder dran gedacht, im Stream mal sowas zu bauen, noch für mich privat, ich
finde Smart Mirrors ist total overrated, mag irgendwie so einen Wow-Effekt haben, vielleicht
auch zum zeigen oder so, aber die Nützlichkeit hält sich meiner Meinung nach in Grenzen,
weil, ich mein, wozu braucht man ein Smart Mirror, dass man sich das Wetter anzeigen
lassen kann oder was, kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass man nicht morgens eh aufs
Handy guckt, ich brauch doch in meinem Spiegel keine Wetteranzeige für heute, und wenn ich
das richtig gut gemacht hab, dann hab ich eh ein Home Automation Dashboard im Flur hängen,
wo ich da einfach mal drauf gucken kann, oder ich hab eh mal ein Smart, ich versteh den
Sinn von Smart Mirrors ehrlich gesagt nicht.
So, guck mal, easy, also Ikea will, dass man die mottet, ich sags euch, Ikea will, dass
man die mottet, so einfach wie das aufgeht, können sich da China-Chinesen Sachen mal
wirklich was von abschneiden, ok, guck mal, hier haben wir den Kram, also, wir haben,
das find ich nice bei diesem Ikea Ding, die Schweden waren so nett und haben alle Pins
beschriftet drauf gelassen in einer Größe, wo man easy Sachen dran löten kann, die wollen,
dass das gemottet wird, changed my mind, die wollen, dass das gemottet wird, ich mein,
die haben hier oben sogar extra, guckt mal, beschriftete, ups, das rockelt, beschriftete
Pins für Ground, für 5 Volt, für SDA, Clock und alles, das ist, die wollen das, theoretisch
kann man sogar noch einen eigenen Lüfter hier unten dran anschließen und sowas, die wollen
das, so, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir den Kram hier rein, also ich hab mir das
so gedacht, das hab ich nämlich auch in einem Video gesehen, auf YouTube, ich hab mir gedacht,
wir machen den Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor, Luftdruck und Gassensor, den machen wir hier oben rein,
weil hier ist der eigentliche Sensor für die Nanopartikel oder Luftpartikel, das heißt,
ich mache den ESP nicht hier drüber, weil der Luftflow sonst beeinträchtigt wird, mal
gucken, ob der hier reinpasst, aber Leute, das kann ich so nicht machen, da ist der Lüfter
dicht, guck mal, ich krieg den kaum wieder raus, ich glaube, wir müssen den ESP32 nehmen,
weil guckt mal, hier unten ist ein Lüfter, irgendwo, ja, hier unten ist ein Lüfter und
wenn ich den Komplette zumach, ist, glaube ich, nicht so sinnvoll, deswegen mach ich lieber,
vielleicht, guck mal, vielleicht kriegt man den sogar hier neben irgendwie hin, aber
ich glaube, da ist kein Platz, aber das wäre mir natürlich am liebsten, dann würde ich
den Krempel irgendwie hier neben hin kriegen, aber ich glaube, da sind, wisst ihr was, vielleicht
kriegen wir den so hin, guck mal, so ist doch viel besser, so machen wir das, so, und jetzt
geht es noch zu, wartet mal, Alter, ah ne, das geht nicht zu, Mist, da unten muss ja das
USB durch, hier muss das USB durch, das geht nicht, die Einheit mit dem Lüfter kannst
du raus, der Lüfter geht nach vorne raus, echt, ich meine, eher wo der was ansaugt,
meinste, hier geht, hinten bläst er das raus, ja gut, dann könnte man dann auch den anderen
drunter stecken, mal schauen, ich persönlich würde ja lieber den ESP32 nehmen, mal checken,
ob das noch zugeht mit dem ESP32 drin, müsste aber eigentlich, ja wunderbar, kein Problem,
ja, dann flashen wir den nochmal, die kriegt man echt schlecht wieder raus, dann flashen
wir den mal, ich nehme den ESP32, erstens habe ich da mehr von, und ansonsten eigentlich
ist es Overkill, eigentlich ist es Overkill, ich nehme, na, ich nehme den, scheiß drauf,
die kann ich für 2 Euro oder so das Stück nachkaufen, ich nehme den kleinen, kannst
du einen VTuber Avatar im Stream entwickeln, nee, weil ich kenne mich mit sowas nicht aus
und ich bin sehr ungeschickt was so Artist Sachen angeht, aber ich suche schon lange
jemand der sowas machen kann, weil ich will auch einen VTuber, ich will auch einen VTuber
Avatar haben, aber nicht einfach so ein Avatar wie die ganzen, wie die ganzen VTuber Girls,
ich will einen Kekshunder sprich, das heißt es muss jemand sein der ordentlich Blender
3D Models machen kann und sowas, nee hier oben, ich meine man könnte es hier oben an
die Seite machen, ja, ich meine es passt hier relativ gut oben an die Seite, weil einfach
mit Heißkleber festmachen oder so, aber hier oben muss ja schon der Sensor rein, ich heiß
klebere den Sensor hier oben fest und der kommt unten rein, jetzt muss ich nur mal kurz gucken
wie man die Kabel hier hin macht, also so geht es zu, kriege ich denn jetzt die, ich muss
Kabel, also naja doch, Leute mir kann keiner erzählen, mir kann langsam echt keiner mehr
erzählen Ikea will nicht dass man das modet, guck mal, die haben sogar, die haben sogar
eine Führung für Kabel hier neben rein gemacht, wo du die Kabel durch machen kannst, ohne
dass du sie abquetschen musst, das ist doch, das kann ich mir nicht erzählen, dass das
Ikea rein zufällig gemacht hat, die wollen dass man den Kram modet er, ist das meine
Original Stimme, Sekunde, da fällt mir gerade was auf, ich glaube mal ein Mikrofon übersteuert
und keiner sagt was, weil ich musste ja wieder Teams telefonieren, den ganzen Tag und Teams
stellt gerne, naja nicht wirklich großartig, aber Teams stellt gerne an meinen Mikrofon
Settings rum, Pfeiferbeauftragung, das kannst du vergessen, hast du den Avatar von JV Peak
gesehen, der ist, nee, da würde mich mal interessieren wo der den gemacht hat.
Sorry Leute, falls ich heute irgendwelche Subscribers oder so übersehe, aber ich blick da nicht
durch, wenn ich hier am basteln bin und noch Chat gucke und dann ab und zu noch überlegen
muss und es kann sein, dass ich die ein oder anderen Subscriptions übersehe, aber trotzdem
danke schonmal für alle Subs, die es heute gegeben hat bis jetzt, es ist übrigens immer
noch kostenlos mit einem Prime Account, kann man einmal im Monat einen Streamer seiner Wahl,
die Wahl darf natürlich auch gerne auf mich fallen, kostenlos unterstützen und quasi 2,50
Euro an Besos überweisen, übrigens guck mal da, ich hab endlich mir einen Fluxstift gekauft,
der Mini Fluxer, da können wir jetzt hier für Huge Loot Action Fluxen, guck mal hier,
der Fluxer und jetzt ist alles hier schön gefluxed, Gachibas Flux, was ein Satz alter,
Fluxchamp, das ist Flussmittel fürs Lootsen, Albi danke für den Sub, Technik danke, nutzt
du dann einen Computer für die Arbeit, ja und nicht nur einen, alle beide und ein Notebook,
was hier hinten liegt, gut also wie fangen wir das, wie gehen wir das denn jetzt am besten
an, wie gehen wir das am besten an, also erstmal müssen wir gucken, was brauchen wir denn hier
für Anschlüsse, kann man das vielleicht raus machen, das wäre natürlich äußerst praktisch,
wenn ich das löten könnte und raus machen wollte, hab aber Schiss, wenn ich das abmache,
ne das lass ich mal besser, das lass ich mal, dass ich das wieder reinkriege Scheiße, das
macht nämlich ein bisschen fragilen Eindruck hier die Kabels da, so also ich vermute mal,
wir brauchen 5 Volt, also von der Idee her, ich denke mal so machen wir das, wir brauchen
ein Kabel unten hier unten da, 5 Volt, einmal Ground und dann, was brauchen wir denn überhaupt
für diesen Sensor, ich glaube 2 Stück davon, ne, da müssen wir erstmal gucken, wie man
das Zeug anschließt, das gucken wir jetzt mal bei denen bei TASMOTA, WinIkea, WinDrickNingTASMOTA,
die haben da ne schöne Anleitung dazu, was bei mir Max115 sagt, bei ihm auf der Arbeit
wird ihm ein Laptop in die Hand gedrückt, andere Sachen darf man nicht nutzen, VPN haben
wir auch nicht, wir haben extra VMs, VPN haben wir auch nicht mehr, wir haben extra VMs,
die man für sowas benutzen kann, glücklicherweise mittlerweile auch ordentlich bedienbar, hast
du mal Bock ein Linux from scratch zu machen, nö, es gibt so paar gewisse Sachen, da hab
ich, das reizt mich nicht, genauso wie nochmal Chrome von Hand kompilieren, da hab ich auch
kein Bock drauf, jetzt Sachen die kann man machen, die muss man aber nicht machen, so
was haben wir hier sonst, disassembly, gut, das haben wir uns gerade angeguckt, you will
need soldering, ok, was, ok, lass mal kurz just for fun gucken, was empfehlen die für
ein Lötkolben, muss tool, das klingt nach billigstem China-Chinese-Crab, alter, oh nein,
wenn ich das schon sehe, das kommt mir nicht ins Haus, so, wires, ESP-Board, ja ja, haben
wir alle, Spannungswandler, wozu brauchen wir einen Spannungswandler, der ESP, der D1
Mini kann 5 Volt als Input, ah, der verwendet kein D1 Mini, der verwendet ein ESP M3, hast
mal Bock auf einen C++ Stream, wir haben doch schon ein paar Arduino-Sachen hier, bzw.
ESPs programmiert mit C++, bin ich ja immer halb durchgedreht, weil C++ so ein Ultra-Crab
ist, man, äh, C++, es wird jedem Standard sogar noch wirrer, ok, also, was muss man
machen, unplug, unplug two connectors, ne, gut, das ist optional, das muss man nicht
machen, ach, da muss man dran, ich dachte, man kann da direkt dran, chat, warum, das
müssen wir jetzt mal einer erklären, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, warum, warum soll
man an die Pads da oben, warum soll man nicht an die runden Pads, sondern an diese Pads,
also warum soll man an diese Pads da oben und nicht an die da drunter, doch im Prinzip
genau das gleiche, hm, keine Ahnung, Geschmackssache würde ich sagen, oder, die haben die, ja,
haben die gleiche Bezeichnung, guck, die haben, äh, Ground 5 Volt, Ground 5 Volt, Clock,
S, ESPR und Reset, das ist genau der gleiche, sogar in der gleichen Reihenfolge, vielleicht,
vielleicht kommt man hier besser dran, das heißt, man kann die auch mixen miteinander,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ist wenn du ein web server haben willst mit ssl dann ist eh vorbei was ich persönlich
ganz cool finde greif was ein geben von wenen an passen wir dann ok weiter also verzinden
ja ja bla bla wo muss er was dran ist so so schlau bin ich auch so schlau bin ich auch
also bis dahin krieg ich noch hin dass ich kraut und 5 volt brauche warum schreibst du
immer eine einzelne die machen wir aus rufzeichen 1 im chat da habe ich das mal irgendwann versucht
zu erklären und reset wozu brauchen wir reset aber reset und weil man braucht reset braucht
kein reset was das ist der pin used to receive data from
warum verwenden ein reset zum daten empfangen das hätte jetzt komplett falsch gemacht
ich hätte gedacht man braucht hier glock und und dings das da und sonst was hättet ihr
damit gerechnet dass reset der daten pin ist wobei es ist rest das ist nicht reset ok aber
da hätte ich gedacht ja dann ist easy dann ist dann ist easy warum reset
4 extra wires ach hier die da ja ok ja das können wir machen so wie schließt man wie
schließt man das ding an bme 680 wirtschamp also was braucht man da man muss an ok das
ist kann man da jeden pin verwenden für i2c was ist denn der die ich glaube bei das motor
kann man jeden pin dafür das motor i2c wie konfiguriert man das habe ich noch nicht
gemacht ja ich glaube man kann also ich glaube man kann mehr oder weniger den pin auswählen
dann in den in den settings wobei haben die das hier nicht einfach irgendwo drinnen stehen
wie man das motor settings macht das motor configuration ok das motor i2c konfig man
spricht das i2c aus ok ich nicht ok man kann man kann die gpi aus auswählen wie man wie
man lustig ist ich will ich will bloß sicherstellen dass ich nicht dass ich nicht das doppelt
machen muss und wieder ablöten muss und so was hier das da suche ich ok das kann man
also einstellen dann ist ja alles gut das motor bme 680 was braucht man dafür settings
für einfach so hier guckt easy einfach so ok dann nehme ich einfach auch die gleichen
gpio pins ein gutes gut das heißt was für gpio ausnehmen wir am besten welche auf der
gleichen seite und am besten auf der seite wo auch 5 volt ist also irgendwelche pins
unten also nehmen wir pin d4 d3 d2 wir schauen noch mal kurz in die pin belegung rein nicht
dass es irgendwelche reserved sachen sind für reset oder flash oder sowas die 1 mini
dsp 2866 pin out also da dran wollen wir d3 ist für flash ach guck mal d1 und d2 sind
schon starrmäßig scl erst jahr das ist ja alles gut dann ist alles gut ihr reicht doch
dann nehmen wir d4 d4 d2 und d1 das reicht doch mehr brauche ich nicht d4 d2 d1 easy da
machen wir das doch mal dann da machen das doch mal dann löten wir erstmal was dran also
wir machen ich würde vorschlagen wir machen folgendes wir flaschen den hier mit das motor
dann schließen wir den sensor an gucken ob das funktioniert oder wir löten den krempel
hier zuerst dran dann habe ich das hinter mir wir machen das lass mal lass mal kurz überlegen
wie machen wir das am besten also wir brauchen auf jeden fall was hatten das ding hier überhaupt
für für anschlüsse lass mal kurz lass mal kurz schauen v in 3,3 volt die 3,3 volt brauche
ich vom esp das ist wahrscheinlich 3,3 volt sensor gehe ich mal von aus da muss ich mal
schauen was ist denn das bme 680 ist das ein 3,3 volt sensor oder ist das ein verkrafteter
5 volt ach guck mal da ah easy for your convenience we've picked and placed sensor on a pcb 3.3
regulator and some level shifting so it can be easily used for your favorite 3,3 ok denn
das heißt ich brauche leider mal das das heißt ich kann das einfach v in mit an die
5 volt packen und gut ist das ist auch gut das ist ja gut da muss ich mir gar keine Gedanken
drüber machen so das heißt wir brauchen ein schwarzes kabel für ground das man dann am
endeffekt auch die sachen wieder findet wir brauchen ein rotes kabel für 5 volt und dann
chat ihr dürft euch aussuchen was was was nehmen wir wir haben noch wir haben noch drei
sachen zur auswahl daten vom luftsensor brauchen wir ein kabel und zwei kabel für datenübertragung
von dem ding was was wollen wir nehmen wir haben blau,purple,grau,grün,gelb,braun und
orange zur auswahl ihr dürft euch aussuchen gelb,lila,grau ok na rot haben wir schon rot
und schwarz haben wir schon orange na gut das wir haben jetzt zur auswahl gelb,lila,grau
und orange orange wir machen das so wir machen wir machen gelb wir machen gelb lila grau
genau so exellent ok also schauen wir uns das ganze mal an wir brauchen viel kabel braucht
man hier drin ja nicht machen wir hier kurz mal ab weil ich hab doch hier irgendwo den
so viel kabels brauchen wir nicht das reicht ja schon reicht ja schon dicke im endeffekt
guck mal das will ikea doch dass man das hier durch macht oder kann mir keiner was erzählen
dass sie das nicht wollen easy wir machen die kabel vielleicht ein bisschen länger sodass
dass wir auf jeden fall dass wir auf jeden fall genug haben müssen sie ja nicht übertreiben
jetzt so also das hier ist das board das board das muss auf jeden fall die kabel runter also
das heißt im endeffekt wir brauchen auf jeden fall mehr ground kabels machen wir mal ab
brauchen wir zwei stück brauchen zwei stück davon also wir brauchen einmal eins wobei
kann man das jetzt habe ich guck war das so rum ja also wir müssen einmal hier vom runter
dahin beziehungsweise zweimal einmal noch zum klauen von dem sensor dann brauchen wir
fünf volt runter zum esp der esp kommt dann da so so rum rein einmal runter dann brauchen
wir hier noch fünf volt v in aber das mache ich eh hier oben dran das passt dann das ist
nicht so wild zweimal datenkabels so das ist nicht lang ja das müsste eins gehen was
ich habe ich habe mich auf den chat was wer war vivo aktiv keine ahnung so ich muss jetzt
mal meinen lötkolben irgendwo auspacken wir haben etwas etwas wenig platz hier oben müssen
wir mal schauen wie wir das jetzt hinkriegen weil hier neben hier neben ist auch nicht
viel platz jetzt die steckdose direkt neben dran muss man ein bisschen bisschen platz
machen ok auf gehts der lötchamp wo ist er hier ok stellen wir mal hier hin dass es
nicht im weg ist ja ich habe hier nicht sonderlich üppig viel platz in dem setup aber man muss
das hier alles sehen man kann das ding morden ja ich habe letztens ein video gesehen auf
youtube dazu ich glaube ich habe gewackelt ich habe ein video auf youtube gesehen deswegen
habe ich mir auch gedacht wir machen das jetzt ok ich will jetzt erstmal eine zweimal zweimal
ground brauchen wir zweimal ground das müsste ich eigentlich ganz gut hier dran kriegen
als erstes mache ich mal ein bisschen löten übrigens wisst ihr was das gute an dieser
lötstation ist die heizt relativ schnell guck mal ich mache jetzt an so und jetzt zack
und wir haben gleich 360 370 grad easy fertig geheizt das geht sehr zackig so wir machen
tatsächlich erstmal eine runde lötzchen ein bisschen auf die pins dazu brauche ich
eine runde lötzchen komm her so jetzt wird es ein bisschen kompliziert weil ich sehe
immer nicht richtig wenn ich am streben bin und ich hier was versuche zu machen weil eigentlich
müsste ich hier unten was sehen was ich ja nicht mache aber vielleicht haben wir glück
vielleicht können wir das hiermit machen falls man das mal vielleicht vielleicht kriege
ich das wirklich ab wie macht man leute chat kennt jemand von euch diese connectors gibt
es da irgendeinen trick muss man aber im schraubenzieher irgendwas machen oder an irgendeine richtung
ziehen oder so dass das besonders leicht raus geht irgendwie kippen oder ok der ist schon
mal ab easy und der da
also den hier habe ich nicht gecheckt ok easy einfach einfach rohe gewalt und gutes
weil so ist es deutlich angenehmer gerade vielleicht kann ich das sogar hier hinlegen
dann ist weil hier unten ist ja dieses teil drunter dann dann ist es ein bisschen fester
ok jetzt machen wir erstmal bisschen bisschen lötzchen auf die pets mal schauen ob ich
das gescheit sehe und dass ihr was seht ich hoffe mal also ich mache jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen lötzchen hier unten auf die pets drauf
schön wir könnten wir könnten es eigentlich jetzt noch eine runde eine runde fluchsen
was ist mit dem fluchser los warum geht der nicht
warum fluchser fluchser nicht richtig
jetzt fluchser fluchser weiß ich ob ihr das seht
aber richtig schön der dicke fluchst drauf jetzt gut
warum nimmst du nicht die größeren pets wie im tutorial ja wie nimmt er jetzt die
jetzt ich habe mir das tutorials die bilder gar nicht mal geguckt macht er das jetzt auch
an die größeren pets das wollte ich ja eigentlich ursprünglich aber aus irgendwelchen gründen
dachte ich die nehmen die kleinen pets nimmt er auch das große weil wenn er die großen
pets nimmt ach der nimmt auch ja dann ist weil mir sind die großen pets auch deutlich
lieber was für was ist der flugstift dass das lötzchen besser fließt
braucht man nicht wirklich geht ohne leute guckt mal guckt vergleicht
es mal mit der anleitung bei ihm sind die dinger komplett naggisch die kontakte hier
ne und bei meinem hat ikea netterweise bei meinem hat ikea netterweise schon vorverzint
die pets alle seht ihr das also jetzt mal ehrlich ikea will dass man sich den kram
zum modden kauft die haben alle pins drauf die haben alle pins beschriffte drauf und
die haben die pins sogar schon vor ververzint
willst du den ans home netz anschließen naja home netz ans wlan ans wlan ja wir machen
trotzdem noch noch noch noch ein klecks noch ein klecks drauf ohne ohne irgendwie die wartet
mal nur so rum ein klecks drauf ohne die plastikfüßchen hier irgendwie
so was brauchen wir denn reset brauchen wir
jetzt haben wir ansonsten noch reset 5 volt 5 volt round sehr schön next da brauchen wir
die kabels gucken wir mal machen wir mal nach möglichkeit nicht so viel ab ah das ups das
war wahrscheinlich fast schon fast schon ein bisschen viel
brauchen wir nicht viel so ground und brauchen wir einmal für ein esp war bestehend da einmal
für ein esp so diesmal mache ich nicht den fehler wie das letzte mal diesmal mache ich
nicht den fehler wie das letzte mal letztes mal habe ich den fehler gemacht alles da dran
zu löten bevor ich es an esp gelötet habe ich mache es jetzt anders rum ich löte die
kann erst an esp und dann mache ich es an den kram dran ist mehr feifert
übrig gebliebenes lötzchen vorne dran machen so schauen wir mal wir wollen pin 5 volt was
hatten wir gesagt 5 volt ground d4 d2 d1 d3 haben wir ausgelassen
planst du auch den luftreiniger smart zu machen ich habe kein luftreiniger ne ne wir
könnten jetzt mal was testen und zwar benutzt das normalerweise nicht so oft aber in dem
fall bringt es vielleicht was weiß ich ob ihr das jetzt besser seht ich sehe es auf
jeden fall besser von oben jetzt muss ich mich nämlich nicht davor setzen immer fort
kann man nämlich hier oben schön 5 volt 5 volt jawohl sehr schick round round so was
haben wir gesagt 5 volt ground 5 volt d4 d2 d1 so und jetzt kabel champ so 5 volt wir
brauchen noch ein rotes kabel für aber guck mal dass das ungefähr gleich lang ist so
wahrscheinlich dass viel viel zu lang aber in ordnung man wurscht haben wir genug platz
drin ist ja nicht so als hätten wir da irgendwie zu wenig platz in dem gehäuse na geil
gut also 5 volt 5 volt kabels
was geht auch relativ easy was geht easy du meinst den luftreiniger ich habe nicht vor
mir den luftreiniger zu kaufen du meinst starkwind starkwind ist der ikea luftreiniger
ja aber starkwind wollte ich mir gar nicht kaufen ikea benahmung sind eh die besten
alle oder starkwind ok was nehmen wir jetzt wir nehmen den gelben merkt euch das mal jett
wir nehmen den gelben für den anschluss an den luftsensor das heißt der luftsensor
das geht dann nur dass ich das jetzt mir mal kurz im kopf überlege so das kommt dann
da unten rein und der anschluss ist oben da muss aber nicht sonderlich lange sein generell
ist die kabels viel zu lang die kann ich jetzt die hälfte abschneiden cacquade braucht
keiner so lange kabel hier aber besser bisschen mehr spielraum als zu wenig da ich mir jetzt
mal so gelb anschluss luftsensor genau
chat merkt sich das starkwind ist von haus aus schmart schmart ist das genau von haus
aus schmart vornuftig was vornuftig ok das ist ein luftfilter von ikea klingt auf jedenfall
sehr ikea mäßig ja vornuftig also hier sensor so dann brauchen wir noch was haben wir gesagt
koppel
waren wir heute der abisulier champ hat nicht funktioniert warum jetzt aber jetzt aber
hat er jetzt nicht das ist nicht schön das gefällt mir nicht das gefällt mir nicht das
machen wir noch ab das machen wir noch ab jetzt ist ok jetzt auch ja ja jetzt ist gut so und
als letztes noch ein krauen und dann gucken wir mal wie das funktioniert da bin ich bin mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert wir müssen es gleich noch flaschen das ding das hätte ich
eigentlich als erstes machen sollen zu flaschen aber ich ziemlich war ich zu zu zu ppega im
kopf dass ich es geflasht habe dass ich nicht geflasht habe das wäre deutlich sinnvoller
gewesen übrigens wie ist das bei euch stört euch das wenn ihr diese lötsachen einatmet
oder nicht also dass das schlimmste der gefühle das höchste der gefühle was ich davon schon mal
hatte ist kopf weh aber auf dauer ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich wirklich nicht sonderlich
gesund das ist nicht schön das ist nicht schön das gefällt mir nicht ja besser ok gut wir
haben alle kabels dran der rauch nervt ja man kommt in das motor drauf gleich wenn das
wenn das alles angeschlossen ist ja ich habe ich habe mir für sowas mal ein usb lüfter
gekauft den ich daneben stellen kann naja gut bevor wir weitermachen chat das ist eine
sehr gute sehr gute idee flaschen wir erst mal weil bevor ich habe garantiert keinen
bock mehr den krempel als ein pc anzustöpseln wenn ich das eingebaut habe wir flaschen
es erst mal schnell flaschchamp und zwar tesmo taser haben wir doch irgendwo ok es
gibt es eine neues update tesmo taser schitt schitt tesmo taser gut den tesmo taser können
wir gar nicht verwenden wir brauchen das motor all sensors ich weiß gar nicht ob der tesmo
taser das tesmo taisen kann ich habe es gar nicht darüber installiert aber was habe ich
das denn zählt pip install tasmo nee installiert man das ich meine man kann es mit dem esp
tool einfach flaschen ja das geht auch stimmt wir können es ja über die neue webseite
machen die haben doch jetzt so eine tasmotar webserie die haben doch jetzt so eine webseite
für usb gedöns na web usb stimmt stimmt ja ihr habt recht wir brauchen das gar nicht
mehr machen wenn ich nur wüsste wo die ist web flasch ja ja flasch flasching from your
web browser äh wo ist der link tasmotar web installer hier das suche ich genau haben
die all sensors ich brauche all sensors unofficial all sensors das brauche ich weil nur da ist
ein windregning dabei das ist by the way kann das firefox auch wahrscheinlich haben wir
mal chrome auf install ok usb gib ihm usb ich habe keinen freien usb was kann ich denn
hier raus machen das da äh moment leute ich habe keinen freien usb ich muss mal kurz gucken
wo ist denn mein mikrofon dran das kann ich nämlich dann raus machen ja das da ok das
ist das normale mikrofon also nicht das was ich jetzt hier habe connect to virtual machine
poggers remember jawoll da schauen wir mal ob das jetzt mit dem mit dem flaschen funktioniert
über übers web interface das habe ich noch nicht gemacht all sensors brauchen wir das
habe ich im vorfeld schon gesehen connect geht es jetzt wahrscheinlich der hier schauen
wir mal tty usb alles klar ja dann ist es be no port selected weiß ich habe den raus
gewählt usb connect tatsächlich das sind wir das sind wir leute install install das
motor all sensors jawoll erase device next install ich habe noch nie über den browser
geflasht prog prog g gibt auch auf git ein mqtt connectivity ja ich weiß aber wir nehmen
das motor das ist mit abstand am einfachsten wenn es denn dann mal drauf ist so ich mache
schon mal mein ipad ich zucke schon mal mein ipad dass ich den sensor wlan technisch einrichten
kann da dürft ihr dann aber nicht zugucken weil ich will mein wlan password nicht on
stream leaken warum nicht wir machen auch nix ich kenne euch also ihr werdet die letzten
die was machen wenn ich mein wlan password liege beziehungsweise wenn ich irgendwelche
account account password da liege ihr werdet die letzten die was macht ne ich weiß ich
weiß ja ja ich erinnere mich noch daran als ich mal aus versehen was war das denn was
ich da geleakt habe 10 minute mail oder irgendwie sowas wo ich dann gleich wo ich dann gleich
subscriptions hatte zum bracer newsletter und und was weiß ich sonstige dinger ich erinnere
mich noch chat ok das motor ah guck mal wir haben ein tas motor gerät gefunden das ist
schon mal gut next nein nein nein wir scannen hier nix nix vor wifi das mache ich selbst
ok
alles klar so dann schließe ich das mal hier an und wir schauen mal ob ich das gescheit
konfiguriert kriegen ihr seht habt geplinkt das motor access point da ist er warum warum
startet das ding warum startet das ding jetzt keine wifi konfig soll das jetzt nicht eigentlich
wifi konfig starten beziehungsweise auf die muss jetzt von hand auf die webseite das ist
doch komisch das ist irgendwas mit dem webflasher der vielleicht was anders macht meine ahnung
und hier und eins ne funktioniert alles gut also key pass das seht ihr jetzt nicht und
ich liege jetzt auch keine passwörter so also das muss jetzt mal kurz eingeben user
passwort alles klar safe not now und jetzt muss ich in meinen router gucken ob der kram
eine ip hat und dann geht's weiter das motor hat eine leases irgendwas mit 60 60 113 das
klingt doch gut ping ok so bei so bei empfang alles klar so geht das motor jetzt auf
öffnen da sind wir nice ok das motor kram ist drauf wir können weitermachen ip liegt
oh nein jetzt ist aber jetzt vorbei leute ich habe meine ip geliegt shit ich muss euch
übrigens wirklich mal kurz ausmachen muss ntp server und zeug eingeben das problem ist
nicht die ntp server die ich nicht will dass ihr seht sondern eventuelle wifi settings und
gedöns ich weiß nicht genau was passiert wenn ich die konsolen wenn ich die konsolen
ansicht aufmache weiß jetzt aus dem kopf kann ich müssen wir mal schauen konsole geht
auch gerade nicht auf ihr seid jetzt ihr seid jetzt kurz unter euch chat oder oder ihr sagt
ihr guckt nicht hin wenn ich den chat wenn ich wenn ich das fenster aufmache da kann
ich euch doch bestimmt trauen wenn ihr sagt ihr guckt mich hin
ja ja ich weiß ich weiß immer dem chat kamer prinzipiell was was blind vertrauen das ist
ja allseits bekannt das weiß man ja so ich bin aber auch schon fertig es ist eh nicht
schlimm ist was man da kurz was man da sieht aber man muss ja nicht mehr liegen als sein
muss so fertig also wir haben es geflasht es ist alles da wir können das theoretisch schon
einstellen generic braucht man hier glaube ich generic 18 save sollte es eigentlich neu
starten ja ja ihr dürft wieder gucken ihr dürft die augen aufmachen schätz alles gut
und figure module so und hier können wir den kram dann einstellen ach hier ist ach so ok
was hatten wir noch mal also d4 ist wenn windrick ning ist d4 und dann machen wir so das d1
und d2 wieder die eins und jetzt also die eins ist scl machen wir so die eins ist scl
ist scl sda so main menu gut jetzt haben wir alles konfiguriert am sensor was wir konfigurieren
müssen das heißt im endeffekt wenn ich es jetzt anlöte sollte es eigentlich sofort
funktionieren wofür steht scl und sda boah das eine ist glaube ich clock oder so ich
weiß gar nicht das eine ist ich glaube das eine ist clock und das andere ist data also
ich glaube scl ist clock und das andere ist data oder so ach serial clock ok ja ja genau
was machst du eigentlich beruflich was hast du gelernt ich habe mal fachinformatiker system
integration gelernt 2007 das ist schon ein bisschen her ich bin ja auch alt nicht wie
die ganzen zoomer im chat ja was ich auf der arbeit mache das kannst du dir auf youtube
angucken da habe ich irgendwelche videos zum thema gemacht kannst du entweder das lange
video mit dem noel angucken wo wir uns drüber ausgelassen haben oder du guckst dir mein
video an wo ich aus irgendwelchen gründen für eine gute idee hielt dass oder muss los
wie ihm rein zu hauen na gut wolltest du nicht ein video mit meinem chef das wollte nicht
video mit meinem chef mein ich wollte ich video mit meinem stazubi gemacht ja mit einem anderen
aus der firma der bei der hotline früher gearbeitet hat und irgendwelche horror stories erzählen
kann ja das wollte ich machen ich habe noch ein bettel viel drei gameplay von meinem
chef von vor zehn jahren oder so auf musik hat er mir irgendwann mal gegeben ok so jetzt
muss man erst mal anlöten leute ja auf auf es ist 21 uhr 50 minuten zeit das muss man
jetzt mal machen also löten kann wieder an stellsding hier weg so also das war es ja
eigentlich also wir haben den kram hier alles ordentlich dran ist ok dann mache ich mal
kurz den dinge zum festhalten wieder weg das ist total useless zum größten teil gut
also wie kriegen wir denn jetzt diesen krempel hier dran also wir brauchen wir brauchen fünf
volt und wir brauchen ground das ist erstmal das wichtigste wir schließen erstmal den
air quality sensor an erstmal nur den air quality sensor dann mal schauen was weggeflogen
gerade mal kurz die kabels ein bisschen verlöt zinnen das erhält oder es ist aber sehr
minimalistisch das kabel was ich da ab isoliert habe aber sollte reichen ok also kabel ground
ist der da wir machen 5 volt dran weil wir fangen auf der rechten seite an also 5 volt
so 5 volt kabel dran das habe ich natürlich gewohnt seriously max alter so das ist nicht
der laktrad ne so das hier ist ground ah das funktioniert die kabel sind nicht schlecht
so ground haben wir dran und jetzt brauchen wir noch gelb hatten wir gesagt gelb ist das
kabel oh das ist nicht schön geworden max max so geht das aber nicht das muss ich nochmal
neu machen das sagt das habe ich nicht richtig gesehen
die kunde das muss ich nochmal neu machen das ist müll wobei das brauchen wir eigentlich
jetzt auch erstmal nicht mein konne ist klassisch schön dass du hier den wish her gefunden
hast das muss ich auch mal schnell ordentlich machen seht ihr eigentlich meinen kopf wenn
ich so mache neke jetzt sagt er nein nein lull dabei ist alles sichtbar ah das ist schön
fest pock pock das wir machen das nochmal bisschen ordentlicher ich hoffe dass der kram
auch hält später ja das ist schön das ist schön so und jetzt hier nochmal den gelben
dran nein kapp ja jetzt ist schön fest alles klar so also und d4 haben wir gesagt auf oder
den rest was auch immer rest der da oh den habe ich gar nicht abisoliert mal mal kurz
so und dann schalten wir ein und dann sollte direkt der luftqualitäts sensor funktionieren
sobald ich das usb kabel dran stecke soweit zumindest in der theorie auch gleich funktioniert
alles ah das sieht gut aus das sieht richtig gut aus da ist das habe ich das habe ich gut
hingekriegt guck mal kann man sich kann man sich nicht nicht beschweren ok so schließen
wir mal an und gucken ob es funktioniert schauen wir mal bin bin gespannt bin bin gespannt
ob es funktioniert wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe dann sollte jetzt nämlich auch der sensor
angehen wenn ich das ikea teil einstöpsel also da gucken wir mal ikea stöpseler alles
richtig dran 5 volt ground letzte möglichkeit zu checken 5 volt ground ja alles klar bamm
es hat geplinkt sachen die plinken und nicht rauchen sind schon mal immer gut woop woop
smoke ja da sind wir leute bamm habe ich nicht mit wind dricken eingestellt config module
gpio 4 sind wir noch gpio 4 oder nicht gpio 4 d4 ah ich habe ist ne ne ist doch richtig
d4 ist wind regnen ich muss wahrscheinlich noch config oh oh ne template config template
muss ich machen wait wait a minute bin ich mal mal muss man das jetzt über config module
machen oder config config template ich bin ich bin moment wie macht wie machten der
du das jetzt module parameters ja habe ich gemacht ein
wo ist das problem
habe das mehr oder weniger so wie der dude eingestellt safe drücken keine ahnung vielleicht
bringt der müsste eigentlich mir die werte vom luftqualitäts sensor anzeigen vielleicht
geht leute null der sensor sogar nicht dran ich habe den sensor abgesteckt dass er da
nichts anzeichnet sei relativ klar ab aufwickeln weg damit ich hoffe das geht jetzt wenn ich
das dranschließe also so so und so so jetzt sind wir dran also ich habe doch alles also
controller ist dran auf d4 ist der gelbe und der gelbe ist auf rest das ist eigentlich
alles richtig an eigentlich alles ok ja guck mal mal jetzt funktioniert die hat ja ha wind
dringend pm 2,5 um micrometers in einem kubikmeter luft ne also 48 mikrogramm partikel in einem
kubikmeter luft interpretiere ich das hier richtig ja ist das gut oder schlecht
ich habe keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht wir können das mal ausprobieren ich meine die
luft hier drin ist nicht gut ich habe hier gelöt stinkt die ganze zeit ich ich puste
mal was da passiert macht das irgendwas juckt ihn das soll ich mal rein purzen ich bin mir
gar nicht sicher ob das permanent misst oder oder es aus oder der hat es gerade ausgeschaltet
warte einen minuten der bringt mir auch bis sie oft was ist da los was ist da los was ist
da los meine kurzschlüsse habe ich auch kapituliert ist alles alles sehr nice und ordentlich das
ist der einzige problem
Sag mal, das Ding schallt sich doch aus und ein, oder?
Sehe ich das falsch oder überträgt das einfach nur Daten die ganze Zeit?
Ja wie kann ich denn das jetzt kann ich irgendwie bisschen bisschen staub machen oder irgendwas
das ist ich habe keine ahnung was ich da ich das testen kann ob das funktioniert kärze
oder streich das ist eine super idee ich habe ein feuerzeug hier irgendwo ja bin bei der
war ich bin nicht raucher das ist nur zum nur für schrumpffläuche nur für schrumpffläuche
no cup bringt das was wenn ich mit dem feuerzeug irgendwie so irgendwie mache also keine ahnung
feuerzeug bringt ja nichts oder doch doch guckt mal ein bisschen was gebracht
ein bisschen was gebracht haben desinfektionsmittel gute idee ich könnte ja ich könnte ja gas
ey leute wir können den gassensor testen guck mal jetzt ist wieder runtergegangen das lager
wir können den gassensor testen wenn ich einfach hier drauf drücke da kommt ein bisschen
gas raus oder ja ist das klappt das bei feuerzeug noch dass
dann gas raus kommt wenn man da einfach da drauf drückt ich bin kein feuerzeug experte
gut guck mal jetzt gehts wieder runter das hat tatsächlich das hat reproduzierbar funktioniert
mit dem feuerzeug ich mein ich hab hier noch so eins
ich glaub das andere mal das andere macht mehr mehr partikel
das andere macht mehr partikel wegen diesem komischen feuer
was auch immer ich glaube ich glaube dem schon dass das funktioniert sehr schön gut also
das funktioniert da bin ich happy bist du raucher nein no cup ich hab die feuerzeuge
nur zum schrumpfschlauch für schrumpfschläuche und soll ich euch mal die geilste erfindung
für guck mal 65 geht hoch die geilste erfindung für leute die kein bock haben zu löten aber
mehrere sachen verbinden müssen zeigen ich hols mal kurz
guck mal ich hab jetzt nur einen mittelgroßen geholt das ist eine kombination eine kombination
aus schrumpfschlauch mit lötzin und auto und kleber die das wasserdicht zu macht funktioniert
folgendermaßen ich bräuchte mal ein kabel was ein bisschen dicker ist
aber gerade hier keins egal ich dann zeige ich dann zeige ich euch das jetzt mal damit
es ist ja wurscht
ich hab doch eben noch mehr von diesem kraut mit dem schwarzen kabel abgemacht oder
ja also von der idee funktioniert das folgendermaßen einfach hier ein bisschen von dem von dem
schwarzen kabel man nimmt das ist jetzt zu dünn das das funktioniert das nicht richtig
so man nimmt das isoliert das isoliert das ab ordentlich so an beiden seiten und dann
nimmt man das und dann nimmt man das kann das jetzt nicht
gescheit zeigen das ist ja toll man nimmt das und steckt das hier rein von beiden seiten
zack dass es in die mitte geht und das auch so in die mitte und dann nimmt man feuerzeug
dann nimmt man feuerzeug und schmilzt das in der mitte easy und dann schmilzt das lötzin
und dann kann man den rest noch schrumpfen hier das funktioniert es nicht richtig weil
die kabel die kabel sind zu dünn aber ihr könnt euch glaube ich vorstellen ungefähr
wie es funktioniert und das ist halt richtig richtig nice und ihr habt jetzt ein komplett
verlötetes ich weiß nicht ob man das gescheit erkennt ich muss mal aufbauen das ist noch
ein bisschen heiß ihr habt jetzt ein komplett verlötetes kabel wasserdicht durch das kleber
an der seite und geschrumpft schlauch zusammen ist das dien konform keine ahnung es ist praktisch
es ist praktisch konform das ist das ist wirklich mega nice dieses zeug nur mal so nebenbei
gezeigt ja die dinger sind wirklich die kosten auch nur ein apple und ein eyeball bei amazon
so ein set weiß ich hatte mal plan wie das heißt schrumpfverbinder oder irgendwas lötverbinder
oder irgendwie so in der richtung weiß ich nicht wie das zumindest praktisch ok hat es
jetzt mit dem sensor alles funktioniert er läuft noch er misst noch warum geht der aus
nach einer zeit wisst ihr woran ich glaube dass das liegt glaube das liegt am china chinesen
usb kabel so dumm es klingt ich glaube es liegt am china chinesen usb kabel wüsste
nicht warum der warum der regelmäßig ausgehen sollte ehrlich gesagt gibt er gibt wenig sinn
ok gut also erstmal kurz ein bisschen platz machen hier so jetzt müssen wir noch den
da dran löten das ist der sensor für gas das können wir gleich testen der sensor für
gas für luftdruck luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatur gucken wir mal
gut löten wir das mal dran müssen wir mal kurz gucken welche haben wir gesagt die da
hat sich irgendjemand gemerkt was sdl ist und was sda ist ich weiß wir können es einfach
umstellen das ist kein ding so wir brauchen noch einmal ground und einmal 5 volt dafür
merke ich gerade habe ich schon wieder verdrängt was wärme schrumpfender stoßverbinder quasi
der gachi bassverbinder ok das da das da jetzt habe ich das natürlich
hier dran gemacht das war ziemlich ich brauche nämlich noch was und zwar das hätte ich mal
ordentlich aufwickeln sollen mensch das denn hier ach jetzt weiß ich aber was da vorhin
geflogen ist diese diese zusammenhaltdinger sind darunter geflogen ich brauche ein kurzes
ein sehr kurzes schwarzes kabel noch es muss wirklich nicht lang sein weil das geht im
endeffekt nur von hier nach hier nicht nicht weit so gut ich löte es dann direkt hier
dran und an den sensor was das so an den sensor dann brauchen wir noch ein rotes für 5 volt
auch nicht so lang auch so das reicht dann schauen wir mal ob das mit dem sensor auch
so easy funktioniert und einfach und einfach tut mal gespannt was das mit dem feuerzeug
funktioniert hast du eigentlich schon mal mit skala programmiert nein ich hatte mal
die ehre nicht wirklich großartig was damit zu machen aber wir hatten mal eine software
in erlangen ein bisschen erlangen kram zu lesen und das war absolute zumutung das ganze
besteht nur aus klammern diese programmier sprache man richtig richtig hyper pepega kram
ist das soll wieder einschalten also wer sich wer sich erlangen ausgedacht hat ist
mir auch komplettes rätsel der muss der steht auf jeden fall auf klammern der typ also erlangen
ist was für die für absolute klammer fans habe hier zu wenig platz erlangen da stehen
wirklich die ganze leute muss stehen da auf klammern wie sonst was war sehr clever und
ich frag mich bis heute war was die an klammern so geil finden eigentlich mich mich nervt
das wenn ich um jeden aus so klammern machen muss aber gut die erlangen fans finden das
nice so wie man das jetzt am besten also das muss irgendwie noch hier dran mal schauen
ob ich das da noch dran krieg ohne dass ich ohne dass ich verkacke wir machen erst mal
den da dran in der hoffnung es fällt nicht ab keg weight nein das hat ziemlich gut funktioniert
alles alles noch dicht alles noch dran alles noch gut hier wird es jetzt ein bisschen ekliger
hinzukommen monka es alter da komme ich nicht hin
präge präge leute präge ich glaube präge war erfolgreich ich glaube es hat funktioniert
ja ja ja aber ziemlich gut ziemlich ziemlich stabiler ganze kram macht jedoch den nähe
ich habe kein bock das jetzt abzumachen ok jetzt brauchen wir hier noch ein bisschen
lütze drauf alter mein stich ist zu klein man ich bekomme anfälle guckt euch das mal
so also wir brauchen in was ist denn hier überhaupt was sind das kennt ihr das sind
die doppelt vorhanden die pins fau in doppelt kron doppelt oder wie oder was oder hä die
sieht so aus na gut oder auch nicht zum teufel ist das st 0 cs was was wollen die von mir
das muss das muss ich mir jetzt mal beim hersteller angucken was das was das sein soll gibt es
darüber wie präzise der ekea ich habe keine ahnung welche welche pins sind denn hier
bitteschön was das ist wahrscheinlich 5 voll oder wie oder was haben die irgendwo in den
pinnen ich meine seriously was ist davon was das ist was anderes als das also ich habe
jetzt fau in und grauen schon einmal ja und dann brauche ich was brauche ich sonst noch
spi oder eiskursi ach das ist alles mögliche also brauche ich st 0 wahrscheinlich und s
c oder ja wo schließe ich denn da jetzt was antran was ist denn jetzt was ich bin verwirrt
weil was ist jetzt haben wir nicht in den pinn diagramm oder sowas für nups pdf data
schied data schied vom sensor wiring so was
c s ist clock signal also das heißt ich brauche
ich brauche im endeffekt c s das geht auf scl und was was was brauche ich sonst noch
s c s und dann ich schippselekt ja jetzt bin ich bin ich echt verwirrt wiring ja da kriegen
wir es gezeigt also ja ja kriege ich das mal in groß please ja ich muss fallen ground
s s dings s ok also also da wo sdi steht und da wo sck steht sck ist scl ok alles klar
da war das mal also ich brauche uns jetzt habe ich ausgeschaltet oft gehe wieder an
geht jam so also neben ground ist ja das neben ground und
dann in der mitte ok tja dann keine ahnung das habe ich so noch nicht gesehen so jetzt
haben wir den krempe jetzt brauchen wir die signal dinger und vorher machen wir aber
ground dran ground und 5 volt ok ground und 5 volt dran also v in tja da bräuchte ich
jetzt da mal meine dritte hand oder wenn es auch nur wenn es auch nur das ding hier ist
soll mir auch recht sein hauptsache das bewegt sich jetzt nicht immer deswegen hier so hingestellt
oder da vielleicht dann man so reicht es mir ja schon hauptsache hauptsache es hält ok
also das ist jetzt v in gut v in hält ziemlich gut dann haben wir als nächstes jetzt ich
sollte mal ein stück knete besorgen das machen die ganzen ami channels immer die haben alle
so ein stück knete ok das ist dran
ja eiskursie will ich das verbinden genau so passt also das ist dran auch relativ fest
und relativ gut so und jetzt kommt jetzt kommen die datenleitung dran die muss noch schnell
ein bisschen abisolieren und dann sehen wir sofort ob es funktioniert ich bin wirklich
mal sehr gespannt da lutz denn hin da bin wirklich mal sehr gespannt ob das gleich einfach
funktionieren wird na auf komm her bin ich wirklich gespannt ok also ich nehme ich hab
jetzt vergessen wie rum ich das wie rum ich das gemacht habe die eins keine ahnung ich
kann ich kann sie dann ich kann sie wieder umdrehen also ich mache es jetzt so die zwei
weiß jemand wo ich glock drauf habe ich mache jetzt die zwei mache ich jetzt auf auf das
auf scl schon ob das funktioniert
so achso ich habe euch gar nicht im fullscreen aber ihr verpasst eigentlich auch nichts muss
man noch ein kabel dran machen so jetzt als letztes den da denn ich will
das nicht richtig dran ist kaum kaum denkt man dass man fertig ist bis man nicht fertig
geht ja auch nichts jetzt ist gut jetzt ist gut ok ich schalte mal an und wir gucken ob
es funktioniert easy nach möglichkeit nicht über den china chinesen usb weil das irgendwie
rumspackt wie es aussieht ja aber noch eines doch besser kein china chinesen usb das muss
funktionieren so also ich habe jetzt vielleicht vielleicht muss ich die sache noch rumdrehen
vielleicht habe ich glock vertauscht also ich habe die zwei jetzt auf glock mal gucken
wenn ich tausche ich die zwei dinger und dann funktioniert es dann gut mal gucke der sensor
leuchtet schon mal chat meines funktioniert nope konfig module was habe ich da d2a ich
habe es so war ich habe es genau falsche rum ist auch egal sagt einfach getauscht gucken
wir mal mein zack fertig geht easy obs falsches fall der knopf ja was willst du da mehr uns
die kreml noch schnell einbauen also wir haben jetzt zur auswahl temperature x daubt dass
wir gerade 30 grad ok ok das pendelt sich ein das brach näher das brauche ein bisschen
vielleicht vielleicht ist es vom lötkolben noch ein bisschen warm das pendelt sich jetzt
gerade gerade ein ne ne das pendelt sich das pendelt sich ein alles gut also gas haben
wir noch das testen wir jetzt ob gas funktioniert leute ob der gas sensor tut gucken wir mal
mal gucken was wir hier haben wir haben hier ein neuer zeug weiß nicht der hängt da ein
bisschen blöd aber ok der gas sensor weiß nicht wo ist der sensor überhaupt hier oder
hat ihr geguckt ist das gas hochgegangen gerade ist hoch oder ist das co2 sensor dann ist vielleicht
co2 ich weiß nicht was das für man kann ich kann einfach mal pusten ich kann einfach mal
pusten also da also wenn ich puste geht auf jeden fall die luftfeuchtigkeit hoch und die
temperatur wobei die temperatur ist schon oben ja das das geht also wenn ich es richtig
richtig krass pustchamp mache jetzt geht es ordentlich hoch luftfeuchtigkeit ne ja guck
mal luftfeuchtigkeit ich genau ich blase gerade ja ja geht geht drauf funktioniert ja gut
dann mache ich das doch mal schnell zusammen gachi roll du du du du du du du du du du du
mal gucken wie man das jetzt ja am besten reinkriegen lödkolben kann weg sind fertig
muss man nichts mal machen bis zumindest bisschen mehr platz hier ist ok also jetzt bauen wir
den kram zusammen gut der sensor habe ich gesagt kommt oben rein auf jeden fall sinnvoll
den oben rein zu machen und der hier der esp kommt unten rein irgendwelchen könnten gar
nicht gescheit passen will was ich sehr merkwürdig finde aber in dem usb anschluss lull was zum
ah leute ich muss noch was anderes machen der hat schrauben und ich will nicht dass
der esp sich kurz schließt da ist da muss irgendwas dazwischen stecken ich habe doch
hier bestimmt ich habe doch hier noch so ein bisschen antistatik kram oder so ja komm
mehr massif heilig secure antistatik folie dengan die luftöffnung ach was heilig secure
antistatik stellts so gut so der kram ist oben drin aber das irgendwie busy guck mal
ich hab viel zu lange kabel keck wait alter guckt euch das an viel zu lange kabels aber
letztendlich ist auch wurscht das können wir einfach hier rein machen ich glaube nicht
dass großartig stört habe ich überhaupt richtig rum ein ja ok
so windregning schauen wir mal ich mach nur mal ich mach nur mal kurz zwei zwei schrauben
zu ich habe eine schraube ich habe eine schraube verloren
ach falscher vielleicht mache ich das morgen auch mal off stream ein bisschen
ordentlicher mit den kabellängen die sind nämlich viel zu lang na
denn hier warum geht das nicht zu
gut so ist zu ich mache es dann ich mache es gleich noch richtig zu wir schließen es
jetzt erst noch mal an aber nicht besseren usbc hier irgendwo ja wir haben das raspberry
pie netz teil ist doch gut das nehmen wir jetzt dafür das raspberry pie netz teil das
sollte nur was der hell das sollte nur mehr als ausreichend sein so windregning geht an
er pinkt auch schon mal gut zack da haben wir es da ist er
luftqualität gelb um nicht zu sagen die meine luftqualität sagt so was haben was haben die
denn hier noch für ne da das gleiche wie ich was hat er denn hier iacu core was ist
denn das iacu iacu core was misst das ding co2 und tv ok was was was alles klar ihr wisst
auch bescheid oder bettaschen sun tv oc ne ich kann das fenster nicht aufmachen ich hab
fliegengitter also ich kann das fenster aufmachen aber ich kann es nicht raus machen ich hab
fliegengitter ist das sinnvoll noch so nen sensor wie der da hat wenn der wenn der windregning
schon dinge hat wie viel kosten so ein ding ich bin ja immer fan von möglichst viel in
die sachen rein zu stopfen wenn man schon mal dabei ist irak sensor hat er grad gesucht
lull ne sowas gibt es hier nicht ja mit dem anderen kann ich aber auch erstmal leben so
also unser tasmotor ist der meinung meine luft ist nicht gut weil ich 5 und 2 ich mein
ich kann mal das oh das fenster auf wir können wir können mal das fenster aufmachen weil
ich den rollern unter hab und zeugs hier liegen hab vorm fenster tja aber was ich machen kann
ist ich kanns mal eine andere ecke ich kanns ja ein bisschen weiter weg wo wir nicht so
krass gelötet haben stellen und dann gucken wir mal runter geht oder so dass jetzt irgendwie
besser wird ja guck mal es geht runter seht ihr pock champ massive pock ne jetzt gehts
wieder hoch was wurde bis jetzt an dem ding umgesetzt alles alles eingebauen ok leute
wisst ihr was ich mach die kamera aus und wir machen das fenster mal auf ich muss das
noch mal kurz freiräumen konnte nicht jetzt musst du was breathing bodies was ist was
ist breathing bodies was für ein ding klingt irgendwie unanständig breathing bodies was
so schauen wir mal jetzt müsste es runter gehen ich habs fenster auf steht jetzt steht
jetzt ziemlich direkt am offenen fenster geht auch ziemlich runter windere knigen ich dreh
es mal ein bisschen rum was auch ansauen kann ja guck mal guck mal viel besser ja
seht ihr es funktioniert es wird auch kühler die luftfeuchtigkeit sinkt die artikel gehen
runter funktioniert kann man nix sagen
das ding auf dem ekea basiert ganz einfach weil es billiger ist als selbst bauen du hast
ein ordentliches case dabei du hast ordentlich led vorn ran der sensor ist billiger als wenn
du dir den so kaufst ja ist gar nicht schlecht es ist eigentlich ziemlich gute idee gut dass
es ist also ich habe das ja bin ja selbst nicht auf die idee kommen ich habe ein youtube video
darüber gesehen haben wir gar zu können auch mal ausprobieren weiß sehr schön leute es
ist 22 uhr welchem tutorial ja das ist quasi so die offizielle seite mit also weiß ich
wie offiziell der ist aber die haben für alle tas motor gerätes settings genau ihr wisst
da schon spät ist ja ausgeschaltet übrigens gerade hat euch der stream gefallen ich hoffe
mal ob mal schnell er kriege
ich bin müde habt ihr lust so was das ist nice richtig poggers ja schön dass euch gefallen
hat ich muss jetzt ins bett weil ihr wisst schon spät deswegen jetzt bis denn macht's
gut zu
gehen
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.